- [Reporter] Less than a year after
the US Supreme Court
overturned Roe v. Wade,
(crowd cheers)
the issue of abortion
returned to the high court
where justices decided to
temporarily preserve access
to a drug used in most
medication abortions.
Abortion access across
the US varies greatly
and continues to change.
- What you have today
is you have a situation
that is much more state-specific,
and I would say much more volatile.
- [Reporter] Here's a look
at how the abortion landscape has changed
since Roe v. Wade was overturned.
(crowd cheers)
Abortion access is currently
protected in 18 states
and the District of Columbia.
12 states have near-total
bans on abortion.
In 10 states, abortion is
neither banned nor protected.
The remaining 10 states have laws
that significantly limit abortion,
but not all of them are
currently being enforced.
- Some of the most striking
changes you've seen
are in Republican-led states
where you've seen abortion go away
and some cases, almost overnight.
- [Reporter] In Florida,
legislators recently passed
a bill banning abortion
after six weeks of pregnancy
with limited exceptions.
Governor Ron DeSantis signed
the bill into law April 13th,
but it isn't poised to go
into effect immediately.
- Florida was one of the few places
in the South where
abortion was still legal.
It saw one of the biggest increases
in abortions after the
overturning of Roe v. Wade.
If this goes into effect,
this will have a significant effect
on abortion access in the
south and around the country.
- At the same time, some
conservative leaning
or politically mixed states
have increased abortion access.
In Michigan, voters approved
a constitutional amendment
enshrining protections
for abortion rights,
nullifying a pre-Roe ban.
Governor Gretchen Whitmer signed
it into law in early April.
- No one is gonna
restrict our reproductive
and our reproductive rights and freedom
in the state, no one.
- [Reporter] As states hash out
their own abortion regulations,
a legal battle has caught
national attention,
and prompted the supreme
court to intervene.
The battle started in Texas
where a district judge
temporarily suspended
the food and drug
administration's approval
of the drug Mifepristone
which is used in most
medication abortions.
- The decision would severely
harm women across the country.
It would deprive patients of a
safe and effective medication
to manage their reproductive health.
- [Reporter] Days later, another ruling
from the Fifth Circuit Court of Appeals
blocked part of that Texas ruling,
allowing Mifepristone
to remain on the market,
but with some significant restrictions
including when the pill can be taken
and how it can be prescribed.
The Biden administration
appealed the Texas decision
and on April 21st, the
supreme court decided
to temporarily preserve
access to Mifepristone
while litigation in
lower courts plays out,
which means, the FDA, drug
makers, and abortion providers
have more time before an official ruling
on Mifepristone is made.
- It's actually the first time
we've seen abortion access
meaningfully in peril,
even in liberal states, even in places
with democratic governors
and democratic legislatures,
because if the FDA were
forced to pull this drug
from the market, that
would affect everyone,
no matter where you live in the country.
(crowd chatter)
(gentle music)